l'école est finie de Julie Chauvin
documentaire qui permet de faire une
exprimée une parole extrêmement forte
vous l'avez entendue on a là des
enseignants qui allaient mal très mal
qui ont pour la plupart changé de voix
c'est bien sûr un zoom sur des instits
en souffrance et toute la question est
de savoir si c'est un prisme déformant
ou bel et bien la réalité quotidienne
des 380 000 enseignants du premier degré
avec nous pour échanger sur ce sujet
Angel previl bienvenue à vous vous êtes
sénatrice socialiste du lot et vous
étiez vous-même professeur avant d'être
élu sénatrice Vincent Ledoux bienvenue
député renaissance du Nord vous avez été
enseignant vous aussi Laurence berguna
bienvenue vous êtes professeur des
universités en sciences de l'éducation
et spécialiste de la santé au travail
vous avez vous-même été institutrice
jusque dans les années 2000 Laurent
zamesjkowski bienvenue vous êtes
vice-président et porte-parole de la
Pepe la Pepe je rappelle que c'est la
Fédération des parents d'élèves de
l'enseignement public merci à tous les
quatre d'être ici je voudrais qu'on
essaye de prendre un petit peu de recul
ensemble par rapport à ce doc umentaire
on a entendu des témoignages très forts
très violents mais peut-être que c'est
un prisme déformant de la réalité
peut-être qu'il y a un zoom sur des
instituteurs et des institutrices
particulièrement en souffrance qu'en
pensez-vous Laurence berguna
tout d'abord je voudrais dire que ce de
témoignage ces témoignages m'ont
énormément
affectés quand même parce que je suis
une ancienne institutrice et je n'avais
pas pris effectivement
autant cette cette ampleur de la
détérioration on va dire de la santé de
des enseignants à ce point bien que je
fais des recherches sur ces aspects-là
sur le stress et le burn-out des
enseignants
je dois dire pour répondre à votre
question que il y a une enquête qui a
été réalisée dans 2016 par la Direction
de l'éducation nationale
qui déjà mentionné que les professeurs
du premier degré était les plus en
difficulté par rapport aux professeurs
du second degré qui rencontrait aussi
beaucoup de difficultés et par rapport
notamment à la majorité de la fonction
publique mais il est ur effectivement de
voir comment
faire que la santé des enseignants
soient bien meilleur ça c'est vraiment
un enjeu majeur Vincent Ledoux je sais
que la question peut déranger et je
l'introduis un petit peu dans mon propos
liminaire mais est-ce que on peut parler
d'un employeur maltraitant quand on
parle de l'éducation nationale et quand
on entend les témoignages que nous avons
entendu dans ce documentaire alors c'est
la vraie question et en même temps quand
je vous écoute madame et puis à
l'observation de ce de ce reportage moi
je prends conscience que j'ai aussi été
maltraité quelque part lorsque j'ai
commencé ma ma carrière d'enseignant
j'étais très peu enseignant finalement
puisque après j'ai abordé rapidement une
un engagement politique mais les tout
début ont été compliqués et avec surtout
personne à qui parler parce que c'est ça
en vérité c'est un peu ça aussi du sujet
c'est difficulté de trouver une oreille
attentive et puis un tuteur qui
m'accueille en me disant mais monsieur
vous allez préparer des concours de
l'ENA vous avez préparé si on se pose ne
restez pas ici voilà c'était une
vocation que tout petit j'avais un petit
tableau chez moi et je recopie avec la
craie toutes mes leçons que ma mère
corrigée est toujours très
scrupuleusement donc j'avais cette
vocation chevillée au corps et puis on
me l'a un peu cassé et on me l'a un peu
cassé parce que les conditions dans
lesquelles j'ai exercé à Roubaix alors
c'est des villes les plus pauvres de
France avec une concentration de
problèmes bien sûr
on fait que je me suis trouvé très très
vite en difficulté avec un niveau de
connaissances que tu es plutôt bon
puisque quand vous passez le CAPES ou
l'agrégation vous avez le niveau de
connaissances qui est je pense suffisant
pour enseigner mais en même temps une
adéquation par rapport à la des classes
qui étaient aussi en souffrance parce
que faut pas oublier que si l'enseignant
est en souffrance généralement la classe
est aussi en souffrance et je voudrais
simplement citer mon chauffeur de
taxisme atteint de Tourcoing Ismaël qui
me dit mais vous savez monsieur le doute
je lui disait que j'allais sur ce
plateau télévision et quel est le quel
en était le sujet il me dit il faut
aussi dire que nos enfants quand le prof
va pas bien nos enfants ne sont pas bien
non plus et je pense que ça aussi c'est
une constellation qu'il faut faire et
donc
y a-t-il maltraitance de
l'administration moi je ne sais pas je
dirais pas jusque là mais en tout cas il
faut entendre cette souffrance et très
très vite il faut apporter naturellement
les solutions et c'est une souffrance
longue puisque la souffrance que j'avais
il y a 25 ans voyez elle perdure encore
voilà et elle s'aggrave d'après les
témoignages qu'on entend j'ai le privil
il y a une situation alarmante oui il y
a une situation alarmante moi je pense
que de la même façon quand j'ai commencé
dans les années 80 c'était ça n'était
pas simple mais la société n'était pas
la même et puis là on sort de deux
années de covid avec beaucoup de
difficultés je pense des enseignants à
gérer ils ont été quand même un petit
peu livré à eux-mêmes pour gérer cette
crise et moi je sais par mes anciens
collègues qu'effectivement moi j'étais
prof en collège à la fin de ma carrière
ça ne se passe pas bien j'ai je sais que
j'ai une collègue qui a fait un burn-out
et c'était quelqu'un très solide donc je
le sais
avant même c'est aggravation de la
situation c'est 2019 voilà donc la
situation
est aggravé très clairement
enfin il aurait fallu quelque part que
l'éducation nationale regarde d'un petit
peu plus près ce qui était en train de
se passer je pense que tout est lié avec
la non reconnaissance du travail par le
salaire on va y venir le fait que plus
personne ne s'engage à devenir prof et
voilà des gens qui se sont abandonnés et
qui font un travail exceptionnel moi
pour toute ma carrière j'ai de ce que
j'ai vécu c'est l'engagement de mes
collègues à travailler le soir le week
ça ça ne se dit pas le week-end et
beaucoup énormément de collègues qui ont
à cœur de bien faire et évidemment le
covid a largement aggraver les choses
parce que là certains sont sentis
complètement démunis c'est sûr qu'on
était face à quelque chose de d'inédit
mais voilà l'accompagnement il a pas été
suffisamment important pour les
collègues pour moi voilà Laurence aussi
c'est intéressant d'avoir le point de
vue des parents aussi parce que souvent
il voit des choses que d'autres ne
voient pas ils sont au courant ils
entendent parler leurs enfants est-ce
que ce que vous avez entendu dans ce
documentaire reflète ce que vous
entendez par ailleurs dans votre dans
votre association évidemment c'est cette
souffrance remonte régulièrement et ce
que dit monsieur est tout à fait vrai
dire difficile d'avoir des élèves qui
font bien si leur enseignants ne va pas
bien donc forcément il y a un impact on
le ressent mais il y a également aussi
un phénomène qui est tendu à toute la
société et justement c'est pas étranger
et malheureusement ce phénomène trouve
ses sources depuis longtemps vous parlez
déjà 25 ans en arrière mais je pense
peut-être encore plus longtemps que ça
c'est une mente descente aux enfers et
on le ressent vraiment et on voit cette
cette tension qui qui monte les gens se
sentent plus soutenus soutenu par leur
hiérarchie c'est très prégnant au sein
de l'éducation nationale est-ce qu'on
est dans l'espace de grande mécanique
administrative où on se sent totalement
en noyer où tout le monde transfère les
responsabilités on sait plus trop qui
fait quoi le manque de formation
également et ça a été ça crée une
situation de crispation et aussi du côté
des parents qui sont également en
détresse qui ne savent plus trop comment
faire ou se situer et quelque part dans
tous cette ce système où tout le monde
va pas bien en fait et ben nos enfants
au milieu sont là et on souffre beaucoup
et après on crée aussi quelque part un
phénomène qui va se répercuter
génération sur génération et quelque
part il y a 7 vagues qui s'est installée
et qui monte et qu'on arrive
malheureusement vers un certain
paroxysme qu'on a pu voir dans ce
documentaire un cercle vicieux alors
avec plus d'un million 200000 agents
dont 860 000 enseignants l'éducation
nationale est effectivement le premier
employeur de France dans le privé une
entreprise de cette taille et même
beaucoup plus petite un certain nombre
d'obligations notamment en termes de
suivi RH ou de suivi médical et bien
apparemment les enseignants n'ont rien
de tout cela écoutez
si j'ai pas de bêtises j'ai une
éducation nationale c'est le premier
employeur de France il n'y a pas de
direction des ressources humaines c'est
quand même moi ça me fait rire de
les seules personnes avec qui on peut
échanger ce sont nos enseignants nos
collègues pardon l'inspection mais
l'inspecteur a un relie hiérarchique et
c'est pas les ressources humaines j'ai
fonctionné pendant 10 ans en tant
qu'enseignant sans jamais voir un
médecin de l'éducation nationale on doit
normalement entrer en faisant une visite
de professionnels j'ai dû voir mon
médecin libéral parce qu'il n'y avait
pas de médecin d'éducation nationale
peut-être que ces demandes à être
clarifié il y a pas de suivi RH il y a
pas de médecine du travail pour les
enseignants du premier degrés alors il y
a plusieurs éléments à ce sujet là
il y a bien une Direction des Ressources
humaines et de récemment depuis un ou
deux ans il y a bien des RH de proximité
mais qui ne sont dont la mission n'est
pas forcément centrée sur la santé des
enseignants ce sont des missions qui
correspondent à de l'accompagnement
de la nation de l'accompagnement par
rapport effectivement à
des opportunités d'avancement mais ce
n'est pas vrai véritablement centré sur
un accompagnement ni sur la prévention
forcément
de la santé des enseignants et ce que je
dois dire aussi c'est que contrairement
au monde du privé dans les entreprises
privées il y a aujourd'hui d'un point de
vue juridique et depuis quand même un
certain temps le droit de de santé au
travail donc il y a des cadres
juridiques tout à fait précis qui oblige
l'employeur dans le secteur privé de
mettre en place des plans de prévention
et ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que dans
la fonction publique nous n'avons pas ce
droit de la santé au travail bien que
sous François Hollande
il y a eu un cadrage quand même non pas
juridique mais quand même une avancée
pour la prévention de la santé dans le
monde enseignant et ça je crois que
c'est vraiment une approche absolument
urgente à avoir de la part du ministère
de l'Éducation nationale d'autant plus
que la France n'a pas une culture de
prévention vraiment santé au travail à
plus pas moins que dans le privé et là
je m'adresse au parlementaire que vous
êtes est-ce qu'il y a pas une
proposition de loi à faire pour
améliorer et recadrer les choses
pourquoi le premier employeur de France
n'est-il pas soumis au même règle que
certainement que les autres
effectivement moi je me souviens quand
j'ai commencé d'avoir eu la visite
médicale organisée par l'Éducation
nationale et puis au fil du temps tous
ces défaits et on avait plus rien il y a
plus assez de médecins ni d'infirmières
d'ailleurs dans les dans les
établissements on n'arrive pas à
recruter donc oui un vrai souci on
vit en fait sur l'éducation nationale
qui était excellente il y a quoi 20-30
ans et puis on a laissé les choses se
déliter donc oui effectivement il y a
certainement une urgence à faire quelque
chose à ce niveau là je pense que en
fait l'éducation nationale est par
exemple des mots de la société c'est ce
que vous évoquiez tout à l'heure c'est à
dire on a une société qui va pas très
bien globalement
la moins de de cadre juridique sur la
santé
qui sur plein de sujets fait
particulièrement de la prévention une
excellence bon on est dans le cadre de
la stratégie nationale de résilience
entre un installer des outils et on le
voit on est en train de penser à la
sécheresse qui va arriver dans cet été
qui est déjà en train d'arriver donc on
est en mode prévention un peu sur un
certain nombre de sujet mais avec un
syndrome de retard et c'est vrai que
notamment sur la santé au travail je
pense qu'il y a encore beaucoup de
progrès même si des choses ont été
faites récemment mais sauf une question
assez il y a des choses vraiment à faire
mais on parle j'ai envie de dire une des
milliers d'enseignants qui sont au
contact de nos enfants tout à ta journée
c'est pas et c'est pas du tout péjoratif
être enseignant à Roubaix ou à Tourcoing
ou être enseignant chez moi à Roncq
c'est pas la même chose parce que vous
êtes face à des publics complètement
différents à des situations sociales
complètement différentes à des parfois
des engagements municipaux publics
l'école c'est le maire qui s'y engage
qui donne les moyens ou pas les moyens
non non mais ça aussi organiser un suivi
médical des enseignants partout ça
semble logique un enseignant qui est en
qui a des problèmes d'alcoolisme de
faire de la prévention à l'obésité
infantile pendant toute ma carrière de
mer j'étais confronté au problème de
l'absence d'infirmière en milieu
scolaire donc vous pouvez pas faire vous
n'avez pas d'indicateurs précis
scientifique et médicaux si vous n'avez
pas les ressources humaines qui vont
avec voilà je voudrais rajouter que le
niveau de la médecine du travail
il se situe ce qu'on appelle en
prévention tertiaire c'est-à-dire au
moment où les personnes il est presque
trop tard c'est le moment où les
personnes doivent être soignées
ça suscite pas mal d'inquiétudes de
savoir que les enseignants n'ont pas de
suivi médical aucun médecin du travail
pendant 20 ans 30 ans les élèves non
plus justement il y a plus d'infirmières
il n'y a plus de médecins scolaire on
parlait aussi dans le documentaire du
raz du réseau d'aide des élèves en
difficulté qui est en disparition
malheureusement tous ces tioles
aujourd'hui c'est un véritable problème
et donc il faut pas oublier
effectivement que le mystère nationale
est le plus gros ministère c'est lui qui
emploie le plus c'est machine trop
centralisée
moi quand j'étais quand j'ai démarré
comme parent délégués lambda sincèrement
c'était totalement incompréhensible
c'était opaque c'était quelque chose de
lunaire pour nous et on se retrouvait et
donc j'ai commencé à apprendre et à
décoder mais je veux dire c'est alors
déjà les acronymes etc qui font arriver
à comprendre mais tout le système et les
et le l'imbrication des dépendances je
veux dire on voit aussi quelque part les
ceux qui interviennent dans le dans le
documentaire ils ont même je pense
qu'ils savent même pas de qui réellement
il dépendent tellement c'est compliqué
les interactions et en plus de ça ils
dépendent de gens qui n'ont pas
forcément non plus la formation
nécessaire pour pouvoir les gérer je
veux dire il y a aussi toute cette
histoire aussi par rapport au fait au
statut du directeur d'école qui est
rejeté aussi par une partie des des
enseignants par réparer syndicats Hiéra
non pas du tout justement c'est
l'inspecteur de circonscription qui est
le directeur d'école est un collègue un
enseignant de l'été de l'école qui
bénéficie d'une décharge partielle ou
totale pour des raisons administratives
mais c'est vrai que c'est induit dans la
formation
c'est un ministère pour moi qui a un
déchiffrable c'est à dire que moi je
fréquente un peu les rouages de l'État
maintenant depuis 7 ans dans mon entrée
en activité parlementaire mais je l'ai
connu quand j'étais mère parce que on
est aussi interface avec l'Éducation
nationale et j'avoue que c'est compliqué
l'éducation c'est un des ministères les
plus cool alors je sais pas vous dire
pourquoi mais c'est complexe
et c'est souvent je vous le dire très
agaçant je quand vous êtes mère c'est
très agaçant et donc je pense qu'il y a
aussi toute une attitude un comportement
de cette machine qui doit complètement
changer c'est-à-dire qu'on a un
ministère qui est du 19e 20e siècle avec
une société complètement évoluée dans
tous les paramètres sont en train
d'exploser avec tous les rapports au
travail on en parlait tout à l'heure qui
est en train de changer aussi enfin tout
est en notre société est en rupture
totale et un ministère qui a l'air
inamovible qui bouge pas alors c'est pas
le procès du ministère que je voudrais
faire ici mais simplement il faut que
cette école elle corresponde à nos
besoins d'aujourd'hui cette c'est une
impérieuse nécessité il faut que nos
enfants enfin moi j'ai souvent dit au
ministre successifs ma grand-mère est
décédée à 90 ans elle est à l'école
jusqu'au 11 ans à 13 ans elle était à
l'usine bon et ben quand elle est
décédée elle écrivait elle parlait très
très bien elle disait très très bien il
y a pas de souci faisait pas de fautes
pratiquement donc on a aussi à
s'interroger sur un ensemble de de cet
environnement qui conduit à ça et qui
fait que ça crée la souffrance de
l'enseignant qui caramel être clair et
aussi ça crée de la souffrance et nos
enfants et puis je voudrais aborder un
sujet qu'on aborde pas beaucoup c'est
celui des parents parce que moi j'ai
trop souvent vu des parents
démissionnaires qui viennent déposer
leurs enfants le temps de l'école et
puis après on le récupère et les
enseignants qui galèrent parce que c'est
pas c'est pas c'est pas leur rôle ils
peuvent pas remplacer moi je je continue
à dire les parents vraiment leur rôle
puissant et on en parle parce que ça a
peut-être un lien aussi avec la
rémunération des des Instit oui moi je
voulais dire une chose c'est que on a vu
enfin moi je l'ai vécu on a vu les
choses changer au niveau des chefs
d'établissement et la façon de manager
en quelque sorte l'établissement et on a
vu arriver sans doute des techniques
managériales nouvelles et c'était ça
n'était pas du tout adapté à ce qu'est
un établissement scolaire et et avec des
injonctions avec des objectifs etc donc
on a beaucoup mis la main sur les sur
les enseignants pour les les conduire à
ceci ou cela moi je me souviens quand
même je vais le dire quand il y avait
des nouvelles réformes quel que soit
d'ailleurs les gouvernements on nous est
faire des stages écrire plein de choses
pour juste nous faire comprendre qu'il
allait y avoir une réforme mais sans
tenir compte du tout de ce qu'on pouvait
dire nous la base donc tout ça c'est
installé au fil du temps c'est ces
choses là et c'est délétère moi je ne
pense pas que ce soit la taille qui
fasse même chose ça fonctionnait je
pense plutôt bien dans les années 70
enfin moi c'est le sentiment que j'ai
surtout quand j'ai commencé dans les
années 80 j'avais pas à me plaindre je
trouvais qu'on fonctionnait bien et puis
tous ces défaits au fur et à mesure quoi
dans ce film les enseignants soulèvent
un nom très important de problèmes du
système trop pyramidal au classe
surchargées en passant par la lâcheté de
la hiérarchie quand il y a des sujets de
violence on leur demande tantôt c'est
eux qui le disent d'être psy tantôt
assistant social tantôt éducateur on
leur demande d'initier nos enfants à
tous les enjeux sociétaux citoyenneté
écologie alimentation et même le code de
la route et pourtant le salaire ne suit
pas
je pense que si les salaires étaient
plus attractifs il y aurait plus de
monde c'est sûr c'est sûr
pourquoi est-ce que les cadres ils ont
des salaires hallucinants parce qu'ils
ont 15 personnes sous leur
responsabilité moi j'en ai 25 et c'est
des enfants
il y a pas un problème quelque part vous
travaillez des adultes autonomes qui
sont toute la journée à leur poste moi
je suis toute la journée avec 25 gamins
qui ne sont incapables de se gérer cinq
minutes seul je n'ai même pas le droit
de les laisser cinq minutes seul
je suis avec eux de 9h du matin jusqu'à
16h30 et juste une pause déjeuner
pendant laquelle on est en réunion
elle a raison il y a quelque chose qui
cloche Laurence berguna alors la
question des salaires bien sûr les très
importantes mais au-delà de cette
question des salaires
il ne faut pas oublier que le métier
d'enseignant c'est une vraie mission et
je crois que c'est Manon à un moment
donné Manon je me trompe pas Manon qui
dit dans le reportage je travaille c'est
accord perdu donc il faut savoir que
tous ces métiers là de la relation
humaine sociale d'aide comme pour les
soignants ce sont des métiers qui sont
porteurs d'une idée
et surtout remplie d'une mission à
vouloir bien exercer leur mission et
aujourd'hui cette mission elle est
entravée il nous explique pourquoi je
pourrais donner après des détails donc
ce qui ce qui est fondamental
et c'est ça c'est à dire que les
enseignants puissent retrouver du sens
parce que quand on porte une mission il
faut qu'il y ait du sens des valeurs
derrière
et surtout
il ne faut pas oublier non plus ce
l'histoire du métier dans le sens où ce
sont des c'est la fonction publique et
ce sont ces deux états c'est-à-dire que
l'État à travers son souverain confie à
la fonction publique
des actions à mener donc les enseignants
c'est l'état et comment et c'est pour ça
qu'ils doivent être extrêmement soutenus
valorisé parce qu'ils sont l'état il
représente l'état j'ai quand même
regardé la rémunération pour en revenir
à cette question des salaires d'un
professeur des écoles au moment de sa
titularisation c'est 1698 euros nets par
mois ce sont les chiffres du ministère
de l'Éducation le salaire moyen d'un
cadre en début de carrière c'est environ
2300 euros nets par mois 1698 euros 2300
euros net par mois un écart que que
cette institut ne comprend pas se trouve
totalement injustifié c'est un justifié
parce que quand j'ai commencé ma
carrière par rapport au SMIC si on se
s'était bien plus que maintenant mais
qu'est-ce que ça dit de la valeur
sociale que l'on accorde à l'instituteur
justement et alors c'est un manque de
reconnaissance criant quoi est-ce que ça
fait partie des raisons pour lesquelles
potentiellement les relations serait
aussi tendues avec les parents est-ce
que parfois certains parents considèrent
ou parce que l'instituteur ou
l'institutrice est dévalorisé parce que
socialement elle n'a plus beaucoup de
valeur vu qu'elle est mal payée du coup
les parents se permettraient de recadrer
les professeurs ou de tendre les
relations avec l'instituteur est-ce
qu'il y a de ça je pense pas que ça soit
la question du salaire en tant que tel
parce que la majorité des parents aussi
ne gagnent pas forcément des fortunes
mais en revanche il y a aujourd'hui dans
cette société qui évoluée vers le
consumérisme un rapport qui est très
différent pareil nous pour les
associations parents d'élèves quelque
part aujourd'hui on adhère on nous
demande une forme de résultat on est on
n'est pas on est plus dans la logique du
simple monde associatif et donc
effectivement il y a une évolution des
mentalités et aussi on disait tout à
l'heure cette société qui va pas bien
donc elle est tendue et donc forcément
on a tendance à être beaucoup plus
irritable beaucoup plus inquiet et on a
de plus en plus de cercle vicieux et on
est de plus en plus peur pour nos
enfants et donc forcément ça crée des
tensions et des tensions qui évidemment
n'arrangent pas la situation parce que
au-delà même du salaire bien évidemment
il y a la question des conditions de
travail on a parlé donc bien sûr la
relation avec les parents c'est vrai
mais il y a également aussi la relation
avec les hiérarchies qui est compliqué
je veux dire c'est il y a une inertie
qui est terrible et je veux dire vous
êtes un peu la pression d'être pris là
dedans d'être un sentiment de terrible
de solitude et on le ressent dans les
communications qu'on peut avoir avec les
enseignants et les directeurs d'écoles
c'est terrible et cette machine fait
qu'aujourd'hui quelque part et on voit
de l'autre côté qu'il y a une tout est
petit public on voit quand un espèce de
truc énorme et on arrive au bout on
accouche une souris on a quelques filets
d'eau donc il y a quelque chose qui
montre que ce qui ne marche pas et
quelque part aujourd'hui aussi on ne
valorise pas assez
les enseignants qui sont devant les
élèves parce qu'il y a aussi beaucoup de
gens qui sont employés par l'Éducation
nationale qui ne sont pas devant élèves
qui font un travail très important mais
néanmoins aujourd'hui c'est ceux qui
sont face aux élèves et les parents
aussi n'ont parfaitement compris pendant
la crise du covid ils sont ils sont
retrouvés justement à devoir faire la
classe à la maison gérer les enfants
souvent pas facile en même temps vous
essayez de travailler de faire des
choses comme ça donc aussi même si on
n'a pas certains n'avaient pas forcément
compris au départ ils l'ont compris et
on voit cette difficulté donc c'est sur
les enseignants qui sont face aux
enfants et comme disait l'institutrice
la professeur des écoles le bah oui
effectivement quand on se retrouve et
avec 25 30 gamins bah c'est pas simple
c'est franchement pas simple du tout
c'est vrai que il y a des jeunes jeunes
et non mais bien sûr ils ont pas le
droit de s'absenter et surtout c'est
pour ça que d'ailleurs en maternelle il
y a des Atsems qui peuvent les aider
justement pour emmener un enfant de
toilette et ainsi de suite et en
primaire c'est fini en primaire et
physique on censés être un petit peu
plus automne de ce côté là mais ce que
je veux dire par là c'est que
des jeunes qui arrivent et qui se
retrouvent tout d'un coup confronté une
classe et c'est ce qu'elle expliquait
elle disait que moi j'ai pas cette
personnalité etc bon elle a trouvé elle
a joué le rôle elle l'a trouvé son
équilibre là dedans mais il y en a plein
d'autres qui ont peur et c'est pas
facile et qui partent et qui vont pas
plus loin et qui vont faire autre chose
mais il y a ça aussi et c'est si vous
comprend que c'est vraiment pas simple
et effectivement comme disait monsieur
il y a des contextes qui sont plus
compliqués que d'autres et dans lequel
effectivement les situations se crispent
ils parlent des non remplaçants rentrés
ou ils se retrouvent avec des élèves de
de avec des classes de 50 ans je pense
que la mission vous évoquez tout à
l'heure effectivement c'est une notion
qui évolue fortement il suffit de
regarder une nouvelle génération qui ont
un rapport au travail complètement
différent je le vois bien à travers nos
propres assistants pour 23 24 ans ils
embrassent leur carrière différentes les
médecins voilà d'une manière
complètement différente aujourd'hui ils
sont plus prêts à consacrer comme vous
l'avez fait sans trop se poser de
questions à l'époque complètement et
totalement et pleinement une mission
c'est-à-dire qu'on épousait vraiment une
vocation là on parle de métier et donc
métier vraiment ça nécessite une
re-valorisation salariale bien entendu
parce que le salaire est important il
traduit quelque chose dans la société
puis c'est aussi du pouvoir d'achat
cette valeur là elle est aussi dans le
regard de la société sur les gens
porteurs d'une forme d'autorité moi je
continue à penser que que le maître
d'école il est porteur d'une forme
d'autorité et donc quelque part je pense
que c'est important de d'avoir ce regard
parce que tout est en train de
s'effilocher parce que notre société
change si je peux intervenir je veux
dire juste une chose pour exercer ce
métier il faut vraiment avoir la foi
c'est à dire que il faut que cette
reconnaissance là sont des ce qui
s'engage dans cette mission là qui ont
la vocation ils sont totalement on peut
pas faire ce métier sur la santé vous
l'avez sur les personnes âgées c'est
l'humain tous les métiers mais on ne
peut pas faire ce métier si on n'a pas
la foi parce que c'est un métier
difficile malgré tout c'est un métier
qui engage la personne totalement c'est
à dire quand on est devant une classe on
établit le lien avec la classe on est
toujours en lien avec chacun des élèves
on ressent les choses etc c'est comme ça
que ça fonctionne et je pense que tout
le monde n'a pas la vision et notamment
puisque certains jeunes maintenant
viennent vers le métier sans se rendre
compte de l'engagement très fort qui
sera le leur et ça il faut que ce soit
reconnu avec un salaire on ne peut pas
vivre avec un salaire juste quand on
commence alors qu'on a fait des études
et qu'on s'engage mais de manière si
forte et de pas avoir cette
reconnaissance parce que c'est ça va
être un des un des
un des déclencheurs en fait de la fuite
parce que faire s'engager si fortement
au
en est consacrant un peu moins de temps
à sa famille parce que ça prend du temps
voilà et puis quand on sort de classe ça
a été dit dans le documentaire mais
parfois on est voilà il nous faut du
temps moi je me souviens après mes cours
je rentrais mes filles savaient très
bien je me mettais boire un thé c'était
la demi-heure on me parle pas parce
pense que voilà c'était et puis après
tout revient et elles avaient compris
donc voilà c'est et ça il faut le il
faut et la valorisation enfin moi je
suis désolé mais le salaire là il n'est
plus à la hauteur de ce qu'il devrait
être très clairement et c'est une des
premières choses quand même mais pas que
il faudra aussi adapter l'institution à
ce que les gens souhaitent qu'un exemple
d'un professeur de Sciences Po qui me
disait hier soir dis tu vois aujourd'hui
je fais cours jusque 20h avec des élèves
qui m'ont fait une pétition parce qu'ils
veulent pas travailler jusqu'au 20h et
leur a dit mais attendez les amis vous
êtes très gentil mais vous allez vous
êtes des futurs cadres de mairie vous
allez il y aura pas des places en état
civil pour les 300 personnes à qui je
fais cours donc imaginez que votre fiche
de poste va être celle-là et je pense
aussi c'est la même chose bien sûr que
le salaire est important mais se rendre
compte que c'est un don de soi total que
c'est un engagement de la personne
complet parce que c'est ça en vérité ce
sont des êtres humains qu'on a en face
de soi mais c'est la même chose qu'on
vous soyez quelqu'un c'est la même chose
qu'on vous accompagnez une personne en
difficulté ou une personne âgée voilà
c'est quelque chose qui est très
rapidement la raison pour laquelle
le salaire plus effectivement la
reconnaissance de cette mission c'est
fondamental et si cette mission est
reconnue sur la base effectivement de
ces vocations de cet engagement et sur
des une idée un spirituelle forte c'est
ça il faut aussi que on leur laisse les
marges de manœuvre revenir à la liberté
pédagogique alors vous faites la
transition avec la troisième partie de
cette émission parce qu'on a beaucoup
parlé et à juste titre du mal-être de
ses professeurs des écoles on n'a pas
vraiment parlé des conséquences sur les
enfants sur le niveau des élèves or
lorsqu'une décision du ministère tombe
lorsqu'une réforme est annoncée elle
doit être appliquée et très rapidement
par ses instituteurs et ses
institutrices qui doivent les appliquer
très vite est-ce toujours cohérent
est-ce toujours pour le bien des enfants
on se pose la question juste après ce
nouvel extrait
donc c'est les directives et les
prérogatives ministériels en fait change
selon les mandats politiques et puis je
dirais que ce qui reste permanent c'est
le fait qu'on consulte jamais les
enseignants et qu'on leur balance comme
ça des lois et des directives avec des
thématiques fortes
dans lesquelles il faut s'engager des
projets d'école dans lesquels il faut
s'engager des réformes qu'il faut voilà
mettre en place des réformes qui sont
lourdes de conséquences en termes de
d'emploi du temps des élèves en termes
de rythme des élèves en termes de ces
phénoménal ce que ça peut avoir comme
impact délétère sur l'organisation
pédagogique l'organisation d'un
établissement scolaire c'est énorme
et là très franchement Vincent Ledoux
Angèle Préville tous les partis
politiques sont concernés par ces
ministres qui à peine arrivé au
ministère font leur petite réforme qui
va avoir un impact énorme
vous êtes là peu de temps parce qu'en
général on est un peu de temps quand on
amusait absolument pas de ce ministère
là je vous le dis franchement parce que
c'est moi je voilà je faut faire ça
parce que parce que vous laissez votre
race c'est tout à fait pourquoi parce
que vous sentez que parce que ça va pas
bien comment ils ont dit pour d'autres
ministères et qui ont le problème
forcément il faut réformer voilà mais
moi je reviens à votre à votre
proposition d'avant le petit reportage
c'était de se dire absolument
laissons la liberté aux enseignants oui
mais justement enfin moi je suis
d'accord complètement d'accord avec ça
laisser de la liberté aux enseignants
c'est absolument essentiel et
effectivement alors nous en tant que
parlementaire parce que moi j'ai bien
compris quand je suis arrivé on ne fait
pas des programmes c'est ce qu'on m'a
dit et quand on essaye quand on a eu la
loi école de confiance ou j'ai quand
même fait voter un amendement parce que
pour moi j'avais envie que on remet des
travaux manuels au collège parce que ça
me semblait essentiel j'ai pu l'inscrire
que l'éducation nationale favorise les
travaux manuels mais pas voilà donc
c'est un problème ça aussi parce que
quelque part nous en tant que
parlementaire on ne peut pas intervenir
là-dessus après du côté prof moi j'ai vu
arriver bien évidemment des injonctions
sur la sécurité routière etc bon j'étais
prof de physique j'ai fait des je vais
faire des calculs aux élèves sur les
distances d'arrêt des choses comme ça
donc j'ai réussi à l'intégrer mais c'est
vrai que c'est c'est compliqué très vite
ils sont obligés d'appliquer les
décisions des ministres qui viennent
d'arriver qui veulent comme vous dites
marquer l'histoire et marquer leur
passage au ministère même ce qui va pas
au delà des ministres qui veulent
marquer l'histoire il faut savoir que il
reçoit des injonctions via leurs
inspections
de
répondre à des critères des critères
tout à fait administratifs mais qui
existe déjà dans les rectorats et et
donc il ne comprennent pas pourquoi on
leur demande des actions
administratives des analyses
administratives de faire remonter des
données au ministère alors que c'est
déjà dans les rectorats ça ce sont des
témoignages que j'ai recueillis auprès
des inspecteurs il me dit ça et donc il
y a une pression temporelle telle que on
en oublie les aspects pédagogiques et
l'enjeu majeur aujourd'hui de à l'école
c'est de revenir sur les enjeux
scolaires et pédagogiques et également
de peut-être redonner une grande idée
nationale générale de ce que le pays
attend de son éducation et de son
enseignement et je rajouterai pour
terminer que dans les différentes
réformes successives
ont retiré le monopole des enseignants
devant parmi tout ce qu'ils doivent
faire d'autant plus que les résultats ne
sont pas bons j'ai regardé la dernière
enquête internationale sur les élèves de
CM1 et c'est plus qu'inquiétant les
petits Français affichent les pires
résultats de l'Union européenne en maths
ils affichent un score de 485 points
alors que la moyenne internationale est
à 527 et celle des pays de l'OCDE et de
529 et il régresse puisque lors de la
précédente étude publiée en 2007 ils
obtenaient un score de 487 points ça
veut dire tout ce qu'on dit a quand même
un impact réel sur le niveau de nos
enfants Laurence la majorowski redonnons
confiance aux enseignants laissons les
mener s'ils sont bien formés ce pourquoi
ils sont ils sont faits donc voilà pour
moi c'est ça et bien accompagné aussi
une chose c'est que alors déjà les
enseignants ils ont pas tous le même
point de vue je siège au Conseil
supérieur à l'éducation croyez moi ils
sont pas d'accord entre eux donc ils
sont plein de choses il y a beaucoup de
dissensions entre les différents
syndicats et ils n'ont pas du tout la
même manière de voir les choses
des enseignants non il y en a multitude
après il faut la marge de manœuvre du
ministère
j'en ai vu passer plusieurs ministres je
pense que sonne tous finalement les pas
si grande que ça effectivement ils
arrivent tous à des réforme des rythmes
scolaires par nagea de vaubel Belkacem
elle a eu un impact réel sur le
quotidien des enseignants et des élèves
bien sûr et puis après la réforme a été
décritée et puis on retricote et on
détricote
ce que j'essaie de dire simplement c'est
que entre ce que le ministre promet et
ce qui se passe réellement sur le
terrain il y a quand même une grosse
différence et on voit que si le réseau
n'accepte pas
ses réformes il va petit à petit
l'enterrer la quelque part ne pas s'en
emparer et c'est ce qui fait la
différence cette difficulté à motiver
tout le monde pour aller pour ramener
dans le même sens quand vous avez un
bateau si vous voulez qu'il avance il
faut qu'on rentre tous dans le même sens
et c'est ça le gros problème aujourd'hui
c'est que ça ne fonctionne pas parce
qu'on est bloqué parce que pour
différentes raisons aujourd'hui il y a
on est paralysé et ce qui fait que notre
système s'effrite s'effondre
complètement et on le voit aujourd'hui
et donc il y a une nécessité impérieuse
de pouvoir retrouver une unité pour
pouvoir avancer tous ensemble et pour
les enfants et pour les enseignants et
moi je veux dire quand même une chose
c'est que l'enseignement repose beaucoup
sur la personnalité de l'enseignant et
c'est lui qui va nouer avec ses élèves
et qui va qui va enfin si on formate
trop les enseignants ça n'est pas bon du
tout parce que ça passe par la
personnalité et nous tous on sait pour
avoir connu des professeurs différents
que avec chacun d'entre eux quand ça a
bien marché c'était ça opposait beaucoup
sur la personnalité je trouve qu'on a
oublié cette dimension là la dimension
de la personnalité de l'enseignant qui
va pouvoir faire passer pas mal de
choses d'une manière particulière qui
est la sienne il n'y a pas de recette
pour enseigner et
tous les enseignants sont différents et
par leur personnalité ils vont arriver
s'ils ont la vocation etc de bien faire
juste les aider et puis voilà et ce sera
la conclusion de cet échange de ce débat
merci merci à tous les quatre d'avoir
participé à cette émission merci à vous
de nous avoir suivis comme chaque
semaine à très vite sur Public Sénat
[Musique]